[Musique]
monsieur la police est là
détective est-ce qu'on peut discuter je
vais vous dédommager
stop il est pas de la police c'est le
genre de chose que Max fait il monte ses
petites anciennes toute cette mascarade
pour 1000 dollars
si tu veux arnaquer les gens
qu'est-ce que tu fais ici je voulais te
saluer
j'ai toujours pensé qu'il hériterait de
tout ça il n'a pas la carrière c'est un
faible
[Musique]
bien sûr que je l'aime il est
milliardaires
[Musique]
repose-toi les manches laissez-moi
confiance
tel esprit qui croyait prendre
c'est pour ça qu'il faut jamais plaindre
le pigeon je t'aime vraiment beaucoup je
t'aime beaucoup moi aussi
tu m'as menti je crois qu'on est tous et
chacun fait du mieux qu'il paie tu
causes beaucoup trop d'angoisse à ta
mère et je ne veux pas qu'elle souffre
un peu que je dégage
comment crois-tu de se finirait pas très
bien
[Musique]
qu'est-ce que tu lui as dit je prendrai
un milliard de dollars rien pour
profiter votre compte
en train de rêver non tu restes pas
[Musique]